ما هو شعورك على وجه التحديد تجاه
سلامتك وسلامة عائلتك
لحسن الحظ في
هذين الشهرين اللذين لم أر
زوجي فيها على الإطلاق وكان ذلك في الماضي يمكنني
رؤيته أحيانًا
لفترة قصيرة
وليس في كثير من الأحيان ولكن يمكنني أن
أشعر به جسديًا بجوار  هذا
ليس طبيعيًا ، إنها ليست علاقة طبيعية
عندما لا يستطيع الأطفال رؤية
والدهم ويتعين عليهم التحدث معه
عبر الهاتف ، لذا فإن علاقتنا
متوقفة تمامًا كما هو الحال بالنسبة للعديد من
الأوكرانيين ،
أود أن أقول إن نصف سكاننا
بعيدًا عن بعضنا البعض ونحن مثل كل
عائلة ننتظر لم شملها
مرة أخرى
لقضاء الأمسيات لتناول العشاء
معًا للتحدث مع الأطفال حول
أشياءهم وليس فقط
أشياء أطفالهم ولكن ابنتي
على سبيل المثال شاب بالغ  الآن
لكننا معلقين في
أم ، أنا أحب هذه الصورة
التي نحملها على أه تمامًا مثل تلك
الخزانة في بورودانكا عندما قصف المحتلون
مبنى وقصفوا جميع
المباني هناك ورأينا  هذه الصورة
لأحد المباني
وكان هناك جدار متبقٍ وكان
هناك خزانة ملابس أو خزانة هناك
لم تتضرر ، لذلك نحن نتشبث
ونخبر بعضنا البعض كيف حالك
مثل تلك الخزانة في بورودينكا ،
لذا فأنا "  أحاول التمسك بهذه
الخزانة تمامًا